now gary truly was a remarkable person
i'm sure you're grateful to have known
him
gary waddell passed away earlier this
month at the age of 77 he worked right
here for 32 years before retiring in
2012. he was known by so many as a
broadcasting influence who had a
tremendous reach that's right well over
the past few weeks i've heard so many
stories and of course great memories and
even though i never met gary he
definitely had an impact here in the
community and of course here in the
station very clear
impact here certainly did gary waddell
leaves behind a legacy that will always
echo in our halls
that man is a success it was lived well
laughed often
and loved much many gathered today to
pay tribute to gary waddell because of
him
we should get a greater appreciation for
life
a greater appreciation for our community
a loss for his family and the
broadcasting family at large gary truly
was a remarkable person i'm sure you're
grateful to have known him gary arrived
in las vegas in 1970 working for kork
radio then made his jump to tv in 1980
working for klas tv until his retirement
in 2012. that was the beginning of a
remarkable 32-year career
and he made southern nevada broadcasting
history as the longest anchor and he
joined up with paula gary covered many
of the events and moments that left
lasting impacts on our city from the mgm
fire in 1980 the latest reports are that
the fire is out to the pepcon chemical
explosion
at this morning's nevada delegation
meeting he brought us coverage from
national events like the democratic
convention and the first anniversary of
9 11 at ground zero in new york he
followed along for weeks with nevada's
task force one as they rescued people
trapped in louisiana by hurricane
katrina he will forever be remembered as
a respected and iconic journalist and i
think maybe gary summed up
best to his experience at the time of
retirement and he said you know
i've had a front row seat on the history
of las vegas and so he did and so all of
us were so grateful to tune in to gary
and listening to him to share it and
explain it with us
and they did mention his tarantula
frankie during today's ceremony gary of
course is in the nevada broadcasters
hall of fame the klas hall of fame and
he's won a slew of broadcasting awards